à quelle vitesse vivez vous
nous ne vivons pas tous à la même
vitesse certains vivent ou tout du moins
nous donne l'impression de vivre plus de
choses en moins de temps beau marche le
célèbre dramaturge du xviiie siècle
l'auteur de la devise du quotidien le
figaro beaumarchais qui était aussi un
aventurier a dit si le temps se mesure
par les événements qui le remplissent
j'ai vécu deux cents ans idrissa berkane
lui aussi semble-t-il ne vit pas à la
même vitesse que nous alors qu'il a
seulement la trentaine il a déjà
multiplié les diplômes les jobs les
projets entrepreneuriaux ou humanitaires
les apparitions médiatiques les oeuvres
et je ne connais pas sa vie amoureuse il
a vécu dans plusieurs pays donné des
centaines de conférences publié plus
d'une centaine de vidéos sur you tube
écrit des essais des poèmes et des
chansons de rap à moins de la moitié de
sa vie il a déjà appris et accompli ce
que le mot ordinaires ne pourrez
apprendre ni accomplir lui en plusieurs
vies il nous donne l'impression d'être
pour reprendre l'expression de
beaumarchais un homme de 200 ans tout
particulièrement sur le plan de la
culture générale en la matière comme
pour le reste on peut estimer qu'il
triche ou bien on peut penser qu'il a
des secrets
[Musique]
idc à berkane est un personnage
controversé donc je commence par un
disclaimer cette vidéo n'est pas un
éloge d'idrissa berkane donc si vous ne
l'aimez pas écouté moins jusqu'au bout
cette vidéo n'est pas non plus une
critique d'idrissa berkane donc si vous
l'aimez bien écoutez moi jusqu'au bout
mon but n'est pas de déterminer si des
saveurs kahn est honnête ou malhonnête
s'il a tort ou raison ou plutôt dans
quelle mesure il a tord ou raison mon
but est de découvrir comment il s'y est
pris pour développer si rapidement une
si grande culture générale et de vous
aider à vous inspirer de ces méthodes
pour enrichir efficacement votre propre
culture générale et ainsi mieux
comprendre le monde cela vous sera utile
et quel que soit votre opinion d'idrissa
berkane c'était déjà vrai pour jacques
attali le modèle de ma précédente vidéo
vous pouvez me dire ce que vous pensez
d'idrissa berkane dans les commentaires
mais s'il vous plaît gardez en tête
l'objet de la vidéo et ne cherchait pas
à me ranger dans le camp des partisans
ni dans celui des détracteurs ce n'est
pas ma guerre comme dit rambo c'était
pas ma guerre
qui est idrissa berkane c'est un
français qui aura 36 ans dans quelques
jours comme je voulais dit il a fait
beaucoup de choses il a plusieurs
casquettes mais pour faire simple il est
surtout connu comme conférencier et
écrivain il a émergé dans l'espace
médiatique français grâce au succès de
son essai libérez votre cerveau sortie
fin 2016 il a lancé sa chaîne youtube il
y a deux ans elle a connu un succès qui
me paraît rapide je ne suis pas un
expert de youtube jusqu'à dépassé le
demi million d'abonnés après idrissa
berkane suscite la controverse et cela
essentiellement pour deux raisons tout
d'abord on l'accuse d'avoir gonflé son
cv et ensuite il a pris position contre
les politiques de gestion de la pandémie
de kobe 19 je n'évoquerai pas ces
controverses car ce n'est pas le sujet
de la vidéo si j'ai choisi de
m'intéresser à idrissa bergame c'est
parce que comme ils l'affirment lui même
sur son site il est passionné par le
savoir et la manière dont il se transmet
étant donné qu'il est jeune et donc
qu'il n'existe pas de biographie
d'idrissa berkane et étant donné que je
ne connais pas personnellement j'ai fait
de la rétro ingénierie pour trouver les
principes qui lui ont permis d'acquérir
sa grande culture générale j'ai lu ces
trois livres j'ai regardé la plupart de
ces vidéos youtube la plupart de ces
conférences de ses interviews et
également sa master class sur motor show
dont le titre me laisser penser que je
pourrais y trouver des informations
intéressantes pour mon script vous vous
allez économiser tout ce travail parce
que je vais vous révéler les trois
secrets de la culture générale d'idrissa
berkane et puis pour chaque secret est
je vous dirais également comment vous
pouvez l'appliquer concrètement regardez
donc attentivement cette vidéo jusqu'au
bout et vous serez enrichir votre
culture générale bien plus efficacement
faut-il se doper pour se cultiver on
peut être tenté par ce que rester
concentré à cordes et durablement son
intention par exemple à un livre ou un
conférencier cela n'a rien de naturel on
ne nous en parle pas à l'école mais la
stimulation des performances
intellectuelles est une pratique
ancienne chez les artistes et les
écrivains au 20e siècle les progrès de
la chimie ont multiplié les solutions et
depuis la fin des trente glorieuses
lusage de certains stimulants s'est
banalisé dans des milieux professionnels
compétitives comme la finance la
télévision ou la politique le film
limitless a popularisé le fantasme d'une
super intelligence artificielle une
petite pilule de nzt et nous nous
souvenons de tout ce que nous avons lu
nous réfléchissons à cent à l'heure nous
apprenons des langues en faisant notre
footing et nous pouvons écrire un roman
à succès en une nuit il dresse à berkane
à des petites pilules magiques c'est ça
son secret non non ce n'est pas ça son
premier secret découle de son analyse de
la stimulation artificielle des
performances intellectuelles dans un
milieu particulier pas chez les
financiers ni chez les stars du showbiz
mais à l'école et à l'université
en effet depuis la fin du xxème siècle
des aides de les sens et même des
enfants se font diagnostiqué des
troubles de l'attention puis prescrire
souvent avec la balle voir à
l'initiative des parents des
psychostimulants comme delà des rôles ou
de la ritaline qui permettent de rester
concentré de longues heures c'est un
phénomène préoccupant aux états unis
comme le montre le documentaire tekki
opens intelligence sur ordonnance qui
est disponible sur netflix d'en libérer
votre cerveau idrissa berkane propose de
retourner le problème dans l'autre sens
l'hypothèse qui font de la prescription
des psychostimulants c'est que les
élèves ne sont pas capables en tout cas
pas assez capable d'accorder leur
attention et si c'était au contraire
l'école qui ne savaient pas capter
l'attention et si c'était le système
académique et ses méthodes qui était
impuissant à intéresser les élèves c'est
en tout cas l'avis d'idrissa berkane
selon moi administrés de la ritaline à
nos enfants sous prétexte qu'ils ne sont
pas suffisamment attentif à l'école est
une gigantesque erreur par laquelle on
soigne des bien portants alors qu'on
devrait soigner l'école or vous pouvez
vous aussi retourné le problème dans
l'autre sens à propos de votre culture
générale est-ce forcément de votre faute
si vous n'arrivez pas à aller au bout du
livre que vous vous étiez juré de finir
est ce vraiment parce que vous avez un
déficit de l'attention un problème
médical qui nécessite un traitement que
vous avez presque ou tu oublié de la
conférence à laquelle vous avez assisté
hier en fait c'est bien de votre faute
mais la faute n'est pas celle que vous
pensez vous est fautif parce que vous
n'avez pas appliquer le premier secret
des drisses aberkane stimuler l'intérêt
si vous accordez votre temps et votre
énergie à des choses qui ne vous
intéresse pas vous aurez du mal à vous
concentrez vous n'avancerait pas et vous
ne retiendrez rien en revanche c'est
presque sans effort que vous
développerez votre culture générale en
appliquant votre esprit à des choses qui
vous intéresse alors vous vous dites
peut-être que c'est évident d'accord
mais si c'est si évident pourquoi ne le
faites-vous pas pourquoi ne le
faites-vous pas autant que vous le
devriez puis j'imagine un second type
d'objection si je creuse uniquement les
sujets qui m'intéressent je ne serai
jamais cultivé vous vous dites que les
choses qu'ils ont leur place dans une
bonne culture générale disons un roman
de balzac ou un tableau de picasso vous
vous dites que ce genre de choses sont
forcément chiant tu es bien c'est un
préjugé ce sont en réalité les personnes
qui transmettent les savoirs classique
qui la plupart du temps les rendent
champions et donc si vous voulez les
intégrer pour enrichir votre culture
générale vous devez apprendre à stimuler
votre propre intérêt mais comment faire
en pratique le principe est simple vous
devez faire pour vous même ce que
quelqu'un d'autre ferait pour capter
votre attention et pour trouver des
techniques précises nous pouvons
regarder idrissa bergame eh bien oui
s'il ya bien une chose qu'il sait faire
c'est capté et conserver l'attention des
personnes auxquels ils s'adressent à
l'écrit et encore plus à l'oral
puisqu'il a donné des centaines de
conférences on ne peut pas lui reprocher
de ne pas appliquer ce qu'il prêche
c'est grâce à son exceptionnel talent
pour stimuler l'intérêt de son auditoire
qu'il a conquis si rapidement un public
si large même ses adversaires les plus
virulents lui reconnaisse cette aptitude
qui est un mélange d'éloquence et de
charisme maintenant si vous voulez
stimuler votre propre intérêt comme
idrissa berkane stimule celui de son
audience vous pouvez faire deux choses
tout d'abord privilégier les histoires
ah oui nous adorons les histoires et du
cou présentait du savoir sous la forme
du récit du parcours d'un être humain
avec des rebondissements avec des
dilemmes et des émotions auxquelles nous
pouvons nous identifier cette manière de
faire est très efficace pour stimuler
l'intérêt d'autrui comme le nôtre je
vous donne un exemple si comme moi vous
êtes loin d'être un fan de peinture mais
que vous souhaitez tout de même
comprendre l'apport de picasso à
l'histoire de l'art occidental est bien
dans ce cas ne vous embarquez pas dans
un essai théorique d' analyse des
oeuvres de picasso ne vous rendez pas à
la conférence d'un universitaire
spécialiste du peintre espagnol non
contentez vous de lire la biographie
réputée la plus vivante de picasso et de
manière générale lire des biographies
est un moyen efficace pour développer sa
culture générale la seconde chose que
vous pouvez faire pour stimuler votre
propre intérêt comme idrissa berkane
stimule celui de son audience c'est de
vous intéresser aux anecdotes qu'est ce
qu'une anecdote précisément c'est un
fait étonnant inédit qui excite notre
curiosité quand il sort de l'ordinaire
les conférences et les livres d'idrissa
burqa dans son bourg et on peut même
souvent lui faire le reproche sans être
malhonnête d'empiler les anecdotes
certes bien choisis et raconter au
détriment de l'argumentation mais sur le
plan de la tension c'est redoutablement
efficace à la fin des années 1980
l'entreprise américaine pepsi cola
posséder des sous marins soviétiques
j'ai bien des idées sous marin
soviétique vous avez envie de décrocher
si je vous dis ça l'inventeur nikola
tesla qui était un bel homme à renoncer
à toute relation sexuelle je m'arrête de
parler ou je continue nous adorons les
anecdotes c'est pour ça qu'elles sont
une formidable porte d'entrée vers le
savoir non seulement le caractère
insolite du fai captent notre attention
mais il crée aussi une fixation dans
notre mémoire au point que bien souvent
il nous suffit d'entendre l'anecdote une
seule et unique fois pour nous en
souvenir pendant longtemps ainsi quel
que soit le domaine dans lequel vous
désirez améliorer votre culture générale
commencé par découvrir les faits
étonnants vous en trouverez dans les
biographies dont les recueil d'anecdotes
dans les livres d'idrissa berkane bien
sûr et sur youtube
connaissez vous ce petit homme il s'agit
de facile le match qu un boxeur
ukrainien qui a le même âge que moi à 34
ans et sur cette photo il annonce son
engagement dans l'armée pour défendre
son pays il est même retournée en
ukraine pour prendre les armes je suis
fan de ce boxeur parce qu'il est
certainement le plus technique de tous
les temps quand j'en parle à mes amis je
leur explique que c'est comme si peter
parker monter sur un ring impossible de
le toucher il est trop rapide d'ailleurs
le match qu est tellement au dessus du
lot techniquement que ses adversaires
abandonne de découragement pour mettre
fin à l' humiliation ce qui lui a valu
le surnom de nos masses tchenko à partir
de l'espagnol no mas qui signifie pas
plus fini à mes yeux le match qu était
évidemment le meilleur boxeur de tous
les temps jusqu'à ce que je trouve de
solides arguments contre cette opinion
dans la vidéo d'idrissa berkane sur
mohamed ali mais bon ce débat ne vous
intéresse pas si je vous parle de cette
vidéo c'est parce qu'elle m'a fait
découvrir autre chose en lisant la
description je suis tombé sur les
sources et elles sont intéressantes à
deux égards la première chose
intéressante c'est que pour établir sa
hiérarchie des boxeurs idrissa berkane
s'appuie notamment sur des postes d'un
coach de boxe john mcglade sur le forum
cora c'est le forum qui a rendu célèbre
jordan peterson à première vue on se dit
des postes sur un forum c'est pas super
sérieux mais après avoir parcouru les
postes je me suis rendu compte que le
propos du coach de boxe est en réalité
très rationnel et très étayé on comprend
même à lire la description de son profil
qu'il a la religion du fait la seconde
chose intéressante à propos des sources
de la vidéo d'idées les saveurs cannes
c'est comme vous en êtes rendu compte
que tout cela est en anglais or en
france seul une minorité de gens sont
capables de se servir de source en
anglais environ un quart des français
déclarent et maîtrisez l'anglais en 2021
mais comme il s'agit de déclarer une
compétence associé au statut social
c'est probablement moins que ça je
résume ma découverte idrissa berkane a
enrichi sa culture générale en lisant
des analyses techniques en anglais et d
analyse non seulement inédite mais très
qualitative publié dans les postes d'un
coach de boxe américains sur un forum
vous vous cultiver comme ça avant le
deuxième secret dit de laisser berkane
c'est donc de multiplier les formes bien
sûr que vous vous cultiverez en lisant
des livres mais ne confondez pas le
contenu et le contenant comme il devait
savoir qu'elle n'écrit d'en libérer
votre cerveau la valeur d'un livre n'est
pas dans son papier mais dans ces
lettres si vous confiez des livres
écrit-il dans l'âge de la connaissance
de la même taille de la même couleur et
de la même odeur à des chimpanzés ils ne
feront pas de différence entre eux parce
qu'ils verront dans les livres des
objets physiques pas des objets
immatériel ils ne verront pas la nuance
décisive des lettres ne soyons donc pas
des chimpanzés c'est la connaissance qui
nous importe pas l'objet qui la contient
et je dirais encore plus
fondamentalement c'est la connaissance
qui nous importe pas le format dans
lequel elle est exprimée or à notre
époque le savoir est disponible dans de
multiples formats articles des livres
bien sûr mais aussi toutes les
plateformes où l'on peut publier du
contenu écrit comme coura il a également
l'audio la vidéo est enfin n'oublions
pas nous qui avons parfois tendance
surtout depuis les confinements à vivre
dans le digital n'oublions pas la
transmission directe qu'il s'agisse du
cours d'un prof ou d'une discussion avec
un ami si vous vous servez dans tous les
formats disponibles vous avez accès à un
patrimoine culturel bien plus riche et
si vous parlez anglais votre buffet de
connaissances pour parler comme idrissa
berkane votre buffet de connaissances
être encore bien plus vaste l'autre
avantage de varier les formes assez que
vous vous fatiguez - quand vous
contentant d'un seul pour passer quatre
heures dans un bouquin il faut déjà être
motivés mais il est moins difficile en
4h d'ouvrir le bouquin pendant une heure
ou deux de parcourir un forum de
regarder une vidéo youtube et d'écouter
un podcast maintenant que pouvez vous
faire pour mettre en pratique ce
deuxième secret pour ce qui est de
varier les formes à l'écrit l'audio la
vidéo etc je n'ai pas grand chose à vous
dire puisque c'est déjà du concret
lorsque vous vous intéressez à un sujet
l'histoire de la boxe par exemple ne
vous contentez pas du premier livre que
vous trouvez mais chercher la
connaissance partout où elle est
disponible concernant l'anglais en 8 si
vous ne maîtrisez pas cette langue qui
est un peu devenu la langue universelle
de l'occident je vous encourage très
très fortement à vous y mettre si votre
temps est limité vous pouvez vous
inspirer du programme simple que j'ai
suivi pour apprendre le russe une
session sur l'application du holding au
chac jours sans exception de préférence
le matin pour ne pas oublier par les
deux heures par semaine plus c'est mieux
avec un prof pas de grammaire ni de
théories uniquement une conversation
amicale écouter des podcasts par exemple
à la salle de sport comme moi regarder
des séries avec les sous titres pour
l'anglais vous êtes servis tandis que
pour le russe c'était galère enfin il y
a un outil génial pour lire en anglais
c'est le kindle d'amazon vous ignorez le
sens d'un mot poser le doigt dessus et
vous avez la réponse et cela marche
aussi avec les articles que vous trouvez
sur internet et que vous envoyez à votre
kindle j'insiste une dernière fois avant
de passer au secret suivant si vous
voulez avoir accès aux meilleurs
contenus sur à peu près n'importe quel
sujet vous devez maîtriser l'anglais
croyez vous en l'existence des anges
gardiens les anges gardiens se sont dans
plusieurs religions des êtres divins de
second ordre qui comme l'adjectif
l'indiquent ont pour mission de guider
et de protéger certaines personnes pas
mal de fiction se sont déjà emparés du
sujet et je m'y étais intéressé au début
de la vingtaine après avoir écouté le
témoignage d'un homme qui prétendait
avoir échappé à un attentat dans un
aéroport grâce à son âge gardien qui lui
avait dit par télépathie j'imagine de
sortir des toilettes quelques instants
avant que la bombe n'explose j'étais
rapidement tombé sur le livre de
référence qui documente le phénomène
enquête sur l'existence des anges
gardiens de pierre jovanovic je n'étais
pas allé au bout des cinq cents pages
mais j'avais découvrir des histoires
étonnantes à commencer par celle de
l'auteur lui-même qui en se jetant
spontanément sur la gauche sans l'avoir
voulu a miraculeusement esquiver une
balle perdue qui a pulvérisé le pare
brise de sa voiture je me souviens
également du fait divers d'un bébé inde
m après une chute de plusieurs étages
mais pierre jovanovic n'était pas très
branché paranormal avant d'échapper à la
mort il était journaliste spécialisé des
questions scientifiques et
technologiques au très sérieux quotidien
de paris c'est après avoir été sauvé par
son ange gardien qu'il a pris un
tournant spirituelle entre guillemets il
s'est mise à écrire des livres avec un
angle original et surtout déconcertant
pour le mort d'inr pour le dire
grossièrement il mêle la finance et le
surnaturel il donne des explications
religieuse et spirituelle aux phénomènes
économiques pourquoi vous avoir expliqué
tout ça quel est le rapport avec idrissa
berkane et bien j'ai été étonné
d'entendre idrissa berkane faire
référence à pierre jovanovic je ne dis
pas que c'est mal je ne dis pas que
c'est bien je ne dis pas que c'est faux
je ne dis pas que c'est vrai je m'étonne
qui dressait à berkane se servent des
idées de pierre jovanovic pour penser le
monde car je venais beach est un
écrivain très hétérodoxes c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire est controversé peu
d'intellectuels oserait faire référence
à ce genre d'auteur mais idrissa berkane
lui assume de s'intéresser à ce que dit
jovanovic idrissa berkane lui-même a
pris des positions controversées
récemment par exemple en doutant du
résultat de l'élection américaine donc
on pourrait croire que c'est parce qu'il
évolue dans la dissidence qui l'assument
de citer pierre jovanovic mais la vraie
raison c'est qu'idrissa berkane
s'intéresse à tout le monde peu importe
l'idéologie la religion le bord
politique la diversité des invitations
auxquelles il a répondu la diversité des
intervenants qui l'a invitée sur sa
chaîne youtube ainsi que sony des d'une
alliance entre mélenchon et marine pour
battre macron au second tour tout cela
atteste qu'il n'est pas l'homme d'un
camp d'ailleurs dans ses livres comme
dans ses vidéos ses références sont
d'une grande variété idéologique et même
si ces dernières années il faut bien
l'admettre il s'est surtout exprimée sur
des médias et avec des personnes
critiques à l'égard des opinions
dominantes il reste capable d'échanger
avec des partisans des opinions qu'il
critique de les écouter et il ne les
diabolise pas par exemple si j'ai bien
compris il est toujours animé par un
sentiment de sympathie à l'égard de
jacques attali jacques attali qui passe
pourtant lui pour un des grands prêtres
de l'idéologie dominante en france comme
le montre d'ailleurs les commentaires
sur ma précédente vidéo qui lui était
consacré après la multiplication des
formats qui était le deuxième secret le
troisième secret djs à berkane et donc
de multiplier les points de vue vous
voulez que votre culture générale soit
vraiment général alors refusé le
dogmatisme accepté de sortir de la doxa
prenez le risque de penser contre vous
même ne cherchez pas même si c'est le
penchant naturel de l'esprit humain à
confirmer vos croyances intéressez vous
aux idées des pensées qui vous
déplaisent spontanément et alors vous
vous rendrez peut-être compte qu'elles
ne sont pas toutes stupide les opinions
dominantes ne sont pas forcément fausse
elles ne sont pas forcément vrai non
plus mais en vous intéressant à d'autres
opinions même controversé vous vous
constituez un buffet de connaissances
bien plus riches comment faire en
pratique alors je ne vous dis pas de
vous plonger dans des manuels de théorie
de la terre plate vous n'avez même pas
besoin d'aller aussi loin qu idrissa
berkane et de vous intéresser à des
auteurs qui explique les mouvements
financiers à partir de la bible non il y
a plus simple écoutez vos adversaires
vous pensez que les keynésiens sont de
faux économistes désir rationaliste qui
ne sont bons qu'à balancer l'argent
public par les fenêtres écoutez les
quand même essayer de comprendre leur
logique lisez la biographie de kane ce
par exemple pour appliquer les deux
premiers conseils et vous verrez que
tout n'est pas à jeter même pour vous
pensez que les libéraux sont les prêtres
des milliardaires écoutez les quand même
essayer de comprendre leur logique lisez
par exemple les sophismes économiques de
frédéric bastiat et j'espère que vous
apprécierez la justesse de certaines
idées vous n'êtes pas convaincu comme
moi que le communisme est la solution
aux malheurs de l'humanité
intéressez-vous quand même aux idées de
marx et alors vous reconnaîtrez j'espère
que certaines de ces idées telles
l'importance des rapports de force
économiques nous permettent de mieux
comprendre le monde vous n'êtes pas
convaincu comme moi que le capitalisme
libéral est le meilleur système ne vous
arrêtez pas à cette conviction et
c'était d'écouter les défenseurs du
capitalisme libéral vous pouvez par
exemple lire capitalisme et liberté de
milton friedman bref sortez de votre
zone de confort idéologique je ne dis
pas que c'est facile je suis comme vous
mon sang bout lorsque j'entends
certaines choses mais ce n'est pas mieux
comprendre le monde que servent de
telles réactions
en synthèse les trois secrets de la
culture générale d'idrissa berkane ce
sont deux stimuler votre propre intérêt
de multiplier les formats et de
multiplier les points de vue si vous
mettez en pratique ses secrets vous vous
cultiverez bien plus rapidement voilà
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu et puisqu'elle vous sera utile si
c'est le cas donnez lui un pouce bleus
et puis laisser un commentaire pour
améliorer le référencement de la vidéo
ce n'est pas grand chose et ça m'aide
vraiment vous étiez sur 1000 et de
culture générale rappelez vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
vous intéresser au meilleur de la pensée
alors la vidéo vous a plu j'espère que
oui j'ai une question à vous poser vous
croyez vraiment que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont il parle bien sûr que
non sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
grand chose
et oui il y à 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
[Musique]
et
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'ya pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivés les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez lu
renan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussi s'est développée rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'ils les appliquent les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet ils brillent par
leur culture dans les conversations
c'est dans les débats et ils ont le
recul nécessaire pour faire preuve
d'esprit critique ça vous intéresse et
bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets et
je vous explique comment les appliquer
dès aujourd'hui pour vous cultivez 10
fois plus rapidement sans vous prendre
la tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant haut à droite de la vidéo
souhaitant qu'ils ont sous celui qui est
dans la description de cette vidéo
croyez moi faites le et vous me
remercierez